Çeviri: Saliha Karatepeli
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Küçük bir kız çocuğunun hikâyesinden
bahsetmek istiyorum size.
Üç-dört yaşlarında bir küçük
kız çocuğu hayal edin.
Bir gece evinde uyurken
korkunç bir rüya görüyor.
Daha doğrusu bir kabus görüyor
ve kabusunda uyanıyor uyanmasına
ama ağlaması bir türlü geçmek bilmiyor.
Annesi babası da başucuna
geliyorlar küçük kız çocuğunun.
Ne olduğunu ne bittiğini
anlamaya çalışıyorlar
ve sabaha karşı küçük kız çocuğu
yeniden uykuya dalıyor.
Ertesi sabah uyandığındaysa yani
tekrar gözlerini açtığındaysa
kekeme olarak uyanıyor.
Kekemeliği biliyor musunuz?
Muhakkak biliyorsunuzdur.
Çevrenizde böyle bir konuşma bozukluğu
yaşayan birileri belki vardır.
Yakınlarınızdan birileri.
Hatta şuanda belki bu kocaman salonda
içinizden bazıları böyle olabilir
ama benim aklıma kekeme deyince
Türk sinemasından rahmetli,
Yeşilçam'ın ustalarından
Hâlit Akçatepe gelir.
Çok güzel canlandırırdı, Türk
filmlerinden hatırlıyoruz.
Rahmetli Kemal Sunal
ile oynadığı filmlerde
kekemeliğe güzel bir hayat verirdi.
Güzel karakterler sunardı.
Şimdi, bunu niye anlatıyorum.
Burada bir parantez açmak istiyorum.
Birkaç saniye kendinizi kekeme
olarak hayal etmenizi rica ediyorum.
Acaba hayatınızda neler değişirdi?
Bir şey değişir miydi sizce?
Şu anda bulunduğunuz noktada,
yani şöyle düşünelim:
Bizi olduğumuz gibi kabul eden,
her şeyimizle seven;
elbette gerçek dostlarımız,
ailemiz, yakınlarımız
bizi yine sarıp
sarmalamaya devam ederlerdi,
olduğumuz gibi bağırlarına basarlardı.
Yani o açıdan pek bir şey değişmezdi
ama aslında sorumun özü şu,
yani şunu düşünmenizi
sağlamaya çalışıyorum:
Hayatta bazı nimetlerimiz var,
çokta farkında değiliz.
Bazen kaybettiğimiz zaman
bazen de aradığımız zaman
bulamadığımız şeyler onlar.
Onlardan bir tanesi de bu:
Konuşma yeteneğimiz.
Aslında her sabah kalktığımızda
şükredeceğimiz o kadar fazla şey var ki.
Bunlardan biri ama yanlış anlaşılmasın.
Konuşma bozukluğuna sahip olanlar
ya da konuşma yetisine
sahip olamayan insanlar var aramızda.
Onlar şansız demek istemiyorum.
Böyle bir algı oluşmasın lütfen.
Sadece bazı şeylerin farkına
varmanızı rica ediyorum.
İletişim kurabilmek, konuşabilmek,
derdimizi anlatabilmek
öyle güzel bir şey ki.
Şimdi sevgili
Yıldız Tilbe'yi hatırlıyorum,
onun son dönemde okuduğum
en güzel cümlelerden biri aslında.
Şöyle bir şey diyor galiba:
"Eğer anlaşıyorsanız bazen
kelimelere ihtiyaç yok
ama anlaşamıyorsanız da yüz farklı
dilde ve lehçede konuşsanız da
bazen derdinizi anlatamıyorsunuz."
Öyle mi ? Öyle, ne yazık ki öyle.
Anlaşmak ya da anlaşmamak değil
ama konuşabilmek kadar
güzel bir şey yok diyorum tekrar.
Böyle bir parantezi tekrar
kapatmış olalım
ve tekrar hikayemize geri dönelim.
Üç-dört yaş, dönmeden önce de yine
bir parantez daha açalım.
Bizim konuşmayı öğrenmeye başladığımız
daha doğrusu artık bebeklikten çıkıp
düzgün cümleler
kurabilmeye başladığımız bir yaş.
Bizler sesleri duyarız ve taklit ederiz,
öyle konuşuyoruz.
Şimdi Türkiye,
çok güzel bir coğrafyada yaşıyoruz.
Ülkemiz çok renkli, insanlarımız renkli
ama bir o kadar da farklı dillerimiz var
yani lehçelerimiz var şivelerimiz var.
Doğuya gittiğimizde bambaşka bir şive,
Karadeniz'in şivesi başka
Batı'da başka bir şive,
Ege şivesinin hastasıyım.
Gerçekten de çok güzel bir şivedir.
Peki niye ?
Doğduğunuz ve duyduğunuz seslerle
konuşmaya başlıyorsunuz.
Eğer ben bir Karadeniz ailesinde
doğmuş ve büyümüş olsaydım
muhtemelen yetişkinliğe adım atana kadar
yani 18 yaşıma kadar da ara ara
ailemle her bir araya geldiğimde
Karadeniz şivesiyle konuşmaya
devam edecektim
ama biraz daha büyüdükçe
farklı insanlarla tanıştıkça
kendinize yeni alanlar
yaratmaya başladıkça
kendinizi geliştirebilirsiniz.
Çünkü her zaman söyler
sevgili Erdoğan Alikan da
- benim TRT'den çok değerli
spiker arkadaşım -
dil, yaşayan bir şey ama o yaşayan
bir şeye hayat vermek de bizim elimizde,
ona katkı sağlamak.
Dolayısıyla kendinizi geliştirebilirsiniz.
Bu hayatta, olmaz diye bir şey yok.
Diye düşünüyorum,
elinizden geleni yaptığınız sürece.
Hikayenin sonunu sizlere söylediğimde
ne anlatmak istediğimi
daha net algılayacaksınız aslında.
Şimdi hikayeye geri dönelim.
Dedim ki: düşünmenizi rica ettim değil mi?
Yani kekeme olsaydınız
hayatınızda ne değişirdi diye.
Anne baba da bu endişeyle yani çocuğumun
acaba sosyal hayatı, okul hayatı,
ve hatta ileride seçeceği
meslek hayatını etkileyecek bir durum mu
geçici bir şey mi diye öğrenmek için
zamanın en iyi psikiyatristlerinden
birine doğru yol alıyorlar.
Rahmetli Atalay Yörükoğlu
çok değerli bir psikiyatristti
belki bilenleriniz vardır aranızda.
Onun görüşü şu oluyor
küçük kız çocuğu için:
Ne yazık ki büyük bir travma yaşamış,
o travmanın neticesinde de bu halde.
Elimizden bir şey gelmez, kendi haline
bırakın ve düzeltmeye çalışmayın.
Eğer düzelirse düzelir,
düzelmezse de çare yok.
Eve dönüyorlar anne, baba, aile.
Şöyle bir şey var küçük kız çocuğu
konuşmayı her şeyden çok istiyor.
Kekemeler biraz da geveze olur aslında
bilmiyorum biliyor musunuz.
Keldi kendine, çok bilinçli olmasa da
ayna karşısında konuşma provaları yapıyor,
daha doğrusu konuşmaya çalışıyor.
Burada bir parantez daha açıyorum.
Ayna karşısında konuşmak
ya da kendi kendine konuşmak
sizce delilik mi?
Ne düşünürsünüz bilmiyorum
ama bence öyle değil.
Geçtiğimiz aylarda
bir araştırma gözüme çarptı.
Üstelik İsveçli bilim adamları değil,
İngiliz araştırmacıların yaptığı
bir araştırmaymış bu.
Kendi kendine konuşmanın:
birincisi konsantrasyonu arttırdığı,
ikincisi öz güveni güçlendirdiği yönünde
araştırmalar yapılmış.
Uzun yıllar pazarlamacı olarak
çalışan biri,
işte atıyorum ellili yaşlarından sonra
girişimci olmaya karar verdiğinde
bir psikiyatriste gidiyor
ve psikiyatrist de bunu salık veriyor.
Yani ayna karşısında
kendi kendine prova yap,
uzun çalışmalar yanında
yani hazırlık süreci
çünkü her şey aslında zihnimizde bitiyor.
Zihnimizde bir şeye
hazırlanmak kadar önemli bir şey yok.
O hazırlık sürecinden sonra da
kendi kendine böyle provalar
yapmasını öneriyor.
Bilmiyorum naçizane ben yapıyorum
ve bu haberi gördüğümde de
çok mutlu olmuştum.
Aa! İşte ruh sağlığım bozuk değil.
Bilmiyorum belki aranızda da vardır.
Kendi kendine konuşanlar var mı ?
Bravo! Deli değiliz yani onu anladık.
Şahane!
Çocuk her şeyden çok istiyor
kendi kendine konuşmayı,
provaları yapıyor ve bir gün günün birinde
gerçekten de ilkokul çağına geldiğinde
tıpkı psikiyatristin söylediği gibi
bu sorun kendiliğinden çözülüyor.
Hatta ilkokul ikinci sınıftayken
okuma yarışmasında
birinci olacak derecede.
Ortaokul yıllarına geldiğinde
bir yere gidiyorlar
- teyzesiyle, ailesiyle.
Birini görüyor ve diyor ki: Aa! ilerde
bende tıpkı onun gibi olacağım
ve bu mesleği yapmalıyım.
Yani bir hayal belirmeye
başlıyor kafasında.
Sonra yıllar geçiyor, büyüyüp
bir genç kız olduğunda
üniversite son sınıftayken
hayal ettiği, istediği
ve o zamana kadar da kafasında
uzun yıllar hazırlık yaptığı
ama bir yandan da gerçekten çalıştığı
o mesleğe bir başlangıç yapıyor.
Bir adım atıyor.
Ne oluyor dersiniz?
Hangi mesleği seçiyor sizce?
Evet spiker ya da sunucu oluyor.
Peki bir fotoğraf göstermek istiyorum
size şimdi.
Kime benziyor?
İlk defa söylüyorum. Bu fotoğrafım
evet o hikayede anlattığım
küçük kız çocuğu bendim.
Yani ben küçükken kekemeydim
(Alkışlar)
ve şimdi karşınızda bir spiker,sunucu
hatta bir eğitmen olarak bulunuyorum.
Peki bu hikâyeyi niye anlattım,
niye anlatıyorum?
Seminerlerde sevgili öğrencilerle
bir araya geldiğimizde de
hep aynı şeyi söylüyorum.
Yıllarca benim için bir sırdı,
sadece ailemin ve çok yakınlarımın
bildiği bir gerçekti.
Bir spiker olarak doğrusu utanırdım ben
konuşma bozukluğu yaşadığımdan zamanında
ve bunu da aşmam
epey zamanımı aldı aslında.
Çünkü kekemeler sonrasında da bu sefer
çok hızlı konuşmaya başlarlar,
benim için de süreç aynı şekilde gelişti.
Bana sorarlar özel yaşantınızda da
böyle mi konuşuyorsunuz diye.
Bende şöyle bir cevap veriyorum:
Tabiki hayır.
Yani bugün çok sevgili kızım
benim yanımda, Damla.
Çok çok teşekkür ediyorum ona
burada enim yanımda olduğu için.
Şöyle bir diyalog geçmiyor aramızda yani
her sabah uyandığında, uyandığımızda.
- Günaydın Damla.
Nasılsın?
İyi uyudun mu?
Ne! Kabus mu gördün? Aman Allahım!
falan gibi bir şey yaşamıyoruz.
Yani böyle bir ses tonuyla, tonlamayla
ve bu şekilde konuşmuyorum
ama mesleğimi yaparken ve elbette
sizlerin karşısında
bir sunum gerçekleştireceğim için
kelimelerimi daha özenli seçiyorum.
Artikülasyonuma, hecelerime, vurgularıma
daha fazla dikkat etmeye
çalışıyorum ama hayat.
Gelgelelim işte hayaller
ve gerçekler dediğimiz şeyler,
ucundan kıyısından biraz yakalayalım.
Ben mesleğime böyle bir başlangıç yaptım.
TRT ile başladım daha sonrasında
özel ajanslarda,
özel kanallarda çalıştım.
Çalıştım allah çalıştım.
Şunu söylemek istiyorum:
Hayatımızda hayallerimiz gerçekten olmalı.
Yani geçenlerde izlediğim bir belgeselde
tesadüfen denk geldim.
İnsanoğlu kadar, hayal kuran galiba
başka bir canlı yok zaten ama
sabahtan akşama kadar hayal kuruyoruz.
İyi de, o hayallerin ne kadarını
gerçekleştiriyoruz
ya da gerçekten acaba ne kadar istiyoruz?
Bütün konuşmacıların ortak noktası buydu,
ben de bu konuya vurgu yapmak istiyorum
ama benim hayatımda
birebir yaşadığım bir şey
olduğu için söylüyorum.
Bir hayaliniz olsun, evet.
Onu gerçekleştirmek için de
elinizden geleni yapın, evet.
Çalışın, evet ama ucundan değil.
Tam da böyle paçasından
yapışmanız gerekiyor.
Çünkü Alice Harikalar Diyarında
diye bir eser vardır,
tıpkı Küçük Prens gibi
yetişkinlikte de okunabilecek bir eser
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ne yazık ki hayat ve dünya öyle değil.
Yani o koridordan, o dünyadan
başka dünyalara geçemiyoruz
ve kimse bize burada olduğu gibi
kırmızı halı sermiyor.
Bu noktaya gelebilmek için ne gerekiyor,
biliyor musunuz hayattın özeti bu aslında.
Bir, azim: yani pes etmemek, vazgeçmemek
çünkü başarı kadar başarısızlık da doğal
ve hayatımızda her zaman
başarısızlıklardan sonra
çok daha fazla başarılı oluyoruz.
Ben bunu gördüm.
Tam da pes etmeye çalıştığımda,
özel kanalda yıllar evvel Kanal D'de
haberciliğe ilk başladığım yerde,
İstanbul'da tek başıma
hayat mücadelesi verdiğimde bir gece
çok kötü bir haber sunumu yaptıktan sonra
"Ben bu işi yapamıyorum,
bu mesleği bırakıyorum,
bu şehirden de gidiyorum" dediğimi
ve sabaha kadar ağladığımı
çok net hatırlıyorum.
Eğer o gece bu mesleği bıraksaydım,
bugünkü Tijen asla olamazdım.
Burada olamazdım.
Bu bir gerçek.
Ve sonrasında da kararlılık.
Gel gelelim hayallerimin de ötesinde
aslında hiç hayal etmediğim
ve aklımın ucundan dahi geçirmediğim
bir olay yaşandı.
Malum kara geceye gelmek istiyorum.
Pek çoğunuzla o geceden
tanışıyoruz zannediyorum.
Allah bir daha yaşatmasın.
Bir kere o dilekleri her seferinde
söylüyorum.
Söylemeye de devam edeceğim.
Gölgesi dahi artık üzerimize,
ülkemize düşmesin.
Darbenin d'si bile telaffuz edilemesin ki
edilemeyecek gibi gözüküyor.
Çünkü geçmişte yaşadıklarımızdan
çok daha farklı, kötü ve kara bir geceydi.
Diyeceksiniz ki; o geceden sonra
ne yapıyorsun, ne oldu?
Bütün merak bu aslında.
Ben hiçbir yerde konuşmadım.
Hiçbir yerde o geceyle ilgili,
bu gece üzerinden ajitasyon sağlamadım.
Beni ve kurumum açısından bakıldığında
son derece izah edilebilir
ve anlaşılabilir kelimelerle,
cümlelerle izah ettik.
O gece herkes bir yerden çünkü
o korkuyu ve çaresizliği yaşadı.
Hepiniz yaşadınız, hepimiz yaşadık
ama ben de çok farklı bir açıdan yaşadım.
Biraz anlatmak istiyorum.
Ben ve ekip arkadaşlarım
her zamanki gibi nöbetimizde iken
haber bültenimizi sunmak üzere
hazırlıklarımızı yaparken
köprülerin kapatıldığı haberini
aldığımız andan itibaren
birbirimize bakıp şu soruyu sorduk:
Ne oluyor?
Bir şeyler oluyor.
Acaba IŞİD'in saldırısı mı ?
Bir savaş alarmı mı?
Ve ne yapmam gerekiyor?
Ve sakin olmam gerekiyor,
az sonra yayına çıkacağım.
Bir konsantrasyon gerektiriyor
bizim habercilik işi
ama halkı da bir yandan
paniğe sevk etmeden
eğer bir alarm durumu varsa,
bir savaş durumu varsa
ona göre cümlelerimi
seçmem gerekiyor.
Ben bu düşünceler içerisindeyken
haber stüdyomuza bir baskın düzenlendi,
asker kılığındaki hainler tarafından
ve bizi IŞİD'in saldırısı yüzünden
orada olduklarına inandırdılar.
O şekilde alı koydular.
Yani Türkiye'deki kamu kurumlarına
bir saldırı ihtimali var
ama aranızda işbirlikçiler olabilir,
hiçbirinize güvenemem
o yüzden de kıpırdayanı
vurma emri aldım dediler
ve bizi yere yatırdılar.
İşte o dakikadan itibaren de
tüm dünya ile irtibatımız kesildi.
Telefonlarımız alı konuldu.
Bizim ellerimiz arkadan bağlı vaziyette
yere yatırıldık.
Aslında bu detayları biliyorsunuz.
O gece de anlattım.
Korku ve çaresizlik, korkunç bir şey.
Ama şunu çok net anlıyorum artık,
bazen filmlerde şöyle şeyler görüyoruz:
İşte hayatım film şeridi gibi
gözümün önünden geçti
Hayır, bilmiyorum bana öyle olmadı yani.
O kadar korkuyorsunuz ki
öyle bir şey düşünemiyorsunuz bile.
Yani Allah kimseye vermesin,
kimseye yaşatmasın
ama benim açımdan bakmak
- biliyorum sizin için zor,
dışarıdan bakıyorsunuz çünkü,
çünkü siz evlerinizde
ya da dışarıda bir yandan
televizyonu izlerken
bir yandan sosyal medyayı takip ederken
ve bir yandan da telefonla
eşinizle dostunuzla konuşurken
benim hiçbir şeyden haberim yoktu.
Bizim bulunduğumuz yerde,
stüdyonun olduğu yerde ve üst katta
elektrikleri kestikleri için
plazmalarda görüntü dahi yoktu
ve ben, okuduğum şeyin ne olduğunu
anlamam için bile bir zaman gerekti.
Evet, ben zorla silah altında
bir şey okuyorum
ve bunun adınada bildiri dediler
ve okumam gerektiği söylendi
silahların altında ama
bu 1980 yılında yaşanan darbe gibi
bir darbe mi değil mi bilmiyorum.
Siz vâkıftınız ama.
İnanın bilmiyorum gecenin 2:00'sinde
stüdyoya halk geldiğinde
Allahu ekber sesleriyle,
tekbirlerle içeri girdiklerinde
arkadaşlarıma sarılıp ağladığımda
"Ne oldu ya? Oldu mu? Olmadı mı?
Bu neydi? Kimdi bunlar?"
sorularımı çok net hatırlıyorum
ve şimdi bu insanlar ne yapıyorlar.
Oysa sokakta insanlar,
çatışmalar yaşanmış, korkunç şeyler olmuş
hiçbirinden haberim yoktu.
Sadece ruh sağlığım bozulmadı,
bir spikerin başına gelebilecek
aslında hayattaki en kötü,
asla hayal edilemeyecek bir şeyi yaşadım.
"Yani devlet kurumunda çalışan bir spiker
en fazla ne yaşayabilir?"
Bu mesleğe başladığımda
düşündüğüm şey:
bir gaf yaparsınız,
bir süre ekrandan çekilirsiniz
ya da başka bir şehirde
görevlendirilirsiniz
ama 2000'lerin Türkiye'sinde
böyle bir şey olacağı
kimin aklına gelirdi ki
benim aklıma gelsin.
Korkunç bir geceydi ve sonrasında
anksiyeteler, panik ataklar
uyku bozuklukları yaşadım.
Geçtiğimiz sene ağustos ayında
bir açık kalp ameliyatı yaşadım ben.
Tümör bulundu, miksoma.
Son iki yılda büyüdüğü tespit edildi.
2.5 cm kadar.
Kalple kıyaslandığında büyük bir tümör
ve her an ölüm tehlikem vardı.
Yani pıhtı atmıştı ve konuşma bozukluğuyla
hastaneye gitmiştim o da ayrı.
Ciddi anlamda ruh sağlığımın yanında
sağlık sorunlarıyla da uğraştım.
Hayatınızda bazen
hayal etmediğiniz şeyler yaşasanız da
hayata tutunmak gerekiyor.
Bana güzel mesajlarla,
ilettiğiniz destek mesajlarınızla
söylediğiniz bir şey var:
" Çok güçlü bir kadınsınız."
Evet, ben güçlü bir kadınım
ve güçlü olmaya da devam edeceğim.
Evladım için, her şey için,
yaşam güzel yaşamak gerekiyor.
Umutla bakmamız gerekiyor.
Karanlıkları aydınlığa çevirmenin
tek yolunun bu olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Sevgiyle.